where did you come in from I came all
the ways from Ireland but I actually
brought something special for you if you
don't mind
wow here we go are you ready
and then you know
I'll wait for you every night wow
if you ever want to fall in love
Hoda copy's Today Show co-host just
pulled a fast one shocking her with a
surprise performance anyone who watches
this show is gonna is gonna see the real
deal it all happened on Wednesday as
Hoda Carson Daly Savannah Guthrie
albroker Chanel Jones and Craig Melvin
greeted fans on the plaza at Rockefeller
Center there are a lot of people who
traveled from far away to come here
today but we think we found the person
who traveled the farthest where is Kian
Kian
traveled the fire
little did Hoda know Kian is an
up-and-coming Irish singer-songwriter
who has gone viral with his surprise
performances if you ever
hear
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
and a surprise performance is exactly
what he delivered live on the morning
show singing his hit single I'll be
waiting I've actually brought something
special for you if you don't mind
wow here we go are you ready
and then you know I'll wait for you
every night wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God yeah Hoda was stunned
this is one of our our aspiring great
new voices coming out this is Andrew
Crow
Ken is uh from Ireland and is just
opened up for Ed Sheeran last month he
was Jonas Brothers it is all happening
in popular music right at this moment uh
for Kian it's great to have you here and
and the choir as well we wanted to
surprise you safe to say their surprise
was a success the world is beautiful as
for Kian he shared this quick clip from
Rockefeller Plaza before all that went
down teasing that something was coming
at 8 30 A.M
[Music]
[Applause]
Kian has over 4 million followers on
Tick Tock where he serves up some epic
content with his impromptu performances
the change
now he's taking his show on the road
yeah well we're actually like I'm going
on tour at the moment which you sold out
in the U.S my first tour and then I'm
gonna
that's really exciting so find me on
tour and while we wait for Kian to make
it to a city near us we'll just be here
watching his Today Show performance on
repeat
[Applause]
[Music]